what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
spider-man 4 updates and i'm talking
about two different spider-man 4s we
have updates today about two different
spider-man 4s one of course about our
current mcu spider-man tom holland and
zendaya returning along with jacob
battle on and the other spider-man 4 of
course being the sam raimi toby maguire
spider-man 4. we also have some details
about the official run time for thor
love and thunder not to mention when
that second trailer is going to be
coming should be coming next week but
we'll talk about that in a bit and of
course we have to talk about the new
daredevil disney plus show that is
coming from marvel studios it is
officially in the works and we know a
little bit of details about what to
expect from that including what other
shows daredevil is going to tie into
we'll break down all of this awesome
news in this video and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news so the first spider-man 4
that we'll talk about is the one that is
with tom holland zendaya jacob babylon
and john watts directing now this is
kind of interesting because this new
report states that sony wants john watts
back to direct the future spider-man
films however recently according to our
knowledge john watts backed out of
directing the fantastic four because he
needed a break from superhero films but
sony seems to be fairly confident that
john watts is going to come back to
direct the next spider-man film and
according to sony they want to start
working on it soon and this information
is actually coming directly from the
source as direct as it can get with sony
chairman tom rothman doing an interview
with deadline they talked about a lot in
this interview but then deadline went on
to talk about those who doubted sony's
strategy and underestimated their
franchise's strength in which rothman
replied that they have uncharted jumanji
spider-man he says we have our marvel
business which breaks into three
tranches there are the spider-man movies
and we're currently at work on two
spider-verse sequels to our
oscar-winning animated movie with lord
and miller and then he says we hope to
get working on the next spider-man movie
in which deadline then asked him with
john watts tom holland and zendaya
returning and rothman replied with that
whole group we hope side note he also
goes into a little bit of the other
project saying that then there are
movies i would call adjunct to the
spider-man universe that's craven which
we're shooting now and madame webb which
will start in the spring with sj
clarkson directing and then there are
many marvel characters that are
standalone so it looks like sony has
quite a bit of plans for their marvel
spider-man universe but obviously the
biggest takeaway here is that sony wants
to start on the next spider-man film
soon and they hope and probably expect
tom hollands and daya jacob battle on to
return but also john watts to possibly
direct the next trilogy he did a pretty
great job with the homecoming trilogy so
i'm sure people would love to have him
back and if they're going to continue
the same story that spider-man knowing
home left off with it would be great to
have him back and it looks like that
that's their plan they are going to
stick to continuing the story of
everybody forgetting who peter parker
was including mj and ned and this is
made pretty apparent since rothman says
that they want the whole group back
you're obviously not going to have them
back if you're not going to continue the
story you can't just start a new story
so for those of you who are wondering if
zendaya is going to return as mj and
jacob returning as ned it looks like
they are and i'm going to assume that at
whatever end this comes to whether
that's another three spider-man films or
just a spider-man 4 whatever it is is
going to end with mj and ned remembering
who peter parker is and hopefully
remembering everything that they went
through however this is not the only
spider-man 4 that fans want to know
about ever since spider-man no way home
brought together the three different
generations of spider-man tom holland
andrew garfield and toby maguire fans
have just been loving it and a bunch of
reports came out after the movie was
released that have been stating that
sony wants and has plans for toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man possibly wanting to give us a
spider-man 4 with tobey maguire after
all sam raimi and toby mcguire were
supposed to do four spider-man films but
they only got to do three and sam raimi
and toby maguire opened up about that
and said that it was pretty hard on them
now sam raimi is back directing for
marvel of course he recently directed
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and now a lot of people are
wondering if he could possibly direct
the mcu spider-man now perhaps direct
the next tom holland trilogy however sam
remy says that he is not going to be
directing any tom holland spider-man
films now it's not because he doesn't
like tom holland as spider-man or he
doesn't like those films it's actually
because he loves and respects toby
maguire too much in a recent interview
with the los angeles times sam raimi
praised spider-man nowy home for opening
up the multiverse and bringing some of
his old friends into one movie he also
had really great things to say about tom
holland and the direction that those
films went he said i love spider-man and
i love tom holland in the role but if i
made a spider-man movie it would
probably have to be with toby or he'd
break my neck and i love that i love
that he started it with tobey maguire
with their three spider-man films and if
he were to come back and do spider-man
he would want that spider-man to be toby
because that's been his buddy for all
these years and it sounds like sam raimi
is actually open to returning which
would make sense because he just
directed multiverse of madness of marvel
film in fact he says he's definitely
open to coming back to direct a
spider-man 4 if marvel is up for it in
the same interview he said i don't know
if marvel would be interested in that
right now i don't know what their
thoughts are about that i haven't really
pursued that but it sounds beautiful
even if it wasn't a spider-man movie i'd
love to work with toby again in a
different role this is great news
because in all of the interviews after
spider-man no way home was released toby
maguire said that right now he's up for
anything so it looks like sam raimi and
toby maguire are both up for spider-man
4 the only thing that kind of needs to
happen now is that sony and marvel need
to green light it i personally really
hope this happens and there were a lot
of reports and a lot of talk after the
movie was released stating that this is
a big possibility and that the studios
are actually talking about it which
would make sense because spider-man no
way home was a massive success so
fingers crossed that things work out for
both spider-man 4s now for some thor
love and thunder news in case you
haven't heard there are some big reports
out there stating that the thor love and
thunder second trailer should be coming
this monday now as far as what time it
could drop i believe the first trailer
dropped at 10 a.m eastern time so if
they're planning on dropping it as the
same time that they dropped the first
trailer that's when you can expect it 10
am eastern time also this is not a final
confirmation and things could always
change but according to the website
cineworld.co.uk
the runtime for thor love and thunder is
going to be 140 minutes so 2 hours and
20 minutes long again this could always
change and may not be accurate but this
is listed on their official site now of
course to finish this off we have to
talk about the big news marvel studios
is officially developing a daredevil
disney plus series this report is coming
from variety who are very big and very
reputable they get a lot of exclusives
and of course there's really no reason
to not believe that a daredevil show is
coming it's been rumored for a while now
and of course we saw him in spiderman no
way home and according to some old
reports we're actually supposed to see
charlie cox's matt murdock slash
daredevil in the mcu a few times before
the series actually comes out now we
know we're going to be seeing him in the
she-hulk series jennifer walters is a
new york lawyer so is matt murdock and
they both represent superheroes so it
just makes sense that their paths would
cross at least a little bit but then we
just got word that the echo series of
course is coming to the mcu which we
knew about but has now been officially
announced and if you know anything about
daredevil and echo in the comics they're
lovers they are really really important
to each other plus not to mention the
main villain of the echo series should
be kingpin and of course we've already
seen him in hawkeye and according to
some reports the events of the echo
series are actually going to lead into
the daredevil series so it sounds like
he's gonna be an echo as well and
hopefully this all eventually leads to a
big fight against kingpin with
spider-man with she-hulk with echo and
daredevil ultimately i hope it leads to
a true sinister six film and they could
have five other heroes joining
spider-man to fight the sinister six and
that's it for our awesome marvel news
this week be sure to let me know what
you are most excited about in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video and subscribe for more marvel
content for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof